I'm guessing that at some point when of
editing this video I am going to be
completely out of ideas and there is
like a massive footage there's just too
much and I remember the able to edit it
together yep
so here's the condensed form for each in
next up is it is a week surrounded by
incredibly creative people and being
exposed to the incredible world of like
big Google big YouTube stuff like and
I've even bet so much in this because
they believe in us they believe that you
know we can make stuff that's
effectively what YouTube Nextup is it's
saying that your people that are doing
really cool things we think you can make
even better things if so we're going to
give you support this week has been
simultaneously one of the most inspiring
and one of the most creatively
disorienting weeks of my life yes now do
YouTube Nextup is an initiative created
by YouTube to encourage the next
generation of content creators it
consists of a week-long workshop in the
YouTube space in central London learning
how to use professional equipment making
most of the analytics and making the
transition to doing YouTube full time I
try vlogging while I was there but to be
honest it was a bit overwhelming we were
just so busy now I'm going to pepper
this video with some of the highlights
of the vlog of the week such as going to
see so we didn't know that so they
bought us all tickets going to work in
the West End
kind of like a cowboy life see it's
pretty cool
oh my god this is so good for here real
reviews will people behind it the Google
people default little drink so thank you
google I I am loving this boot I've only
been a couple of weapon shows before I
Matilda I'm going to be Hamilton that
was really good they didn't tell us
about this than we applied next up we're
so cool oh look over there I'm going
there in a couple of months but it's
finished you great unfinished symphony
right so you're watching this vlog and
you're probably wondering what I learned
on the camp what youtube wisdom have I
received well first of all I learned
that the each community in the UK is so
much bigger and more diverse than I
believed it could be on this camp we had
12 channels as diverse as our own ashes
all about food line of summons about
natural hair and Tyson Edwards all about
functional strength training I'm
including links to everyone's channels
in the description by the way definitely
go and check them out after this video
being surrounded by such a diverse cast
of creative people was a huge boost to
my own creativity this was definitely
one of the main things I took away from
the week especially coming from a part
of the UK where there are just no other
youtubers there's something about being
around people who are super passionate
about the same thing I am making videos
and that Spurs you on makes you want to
create this was something that we
capitalized on by giving us an excellent
workshop in production techniques by
filmmaker simeon quarry another person
whose channel you should check out link
below focusing on lighting simeon
allowed us to be really hands-on and
used the gear and get a sense of what
worked rather than just talking about
the theory it was really great
that's and by the way who has a channel
about men's fashion the second thing
that i learned from the week was that to
grow your channel you have to look
really deep into your analytics this is
the rear end that youtubers get showing
how many people are watching their
videos who's watching their videos and
the feedback you're receiving comments
and likes and such this came from a
series of workshops looking through the
tools at our disposal and there are
depths that even I wasn't aware of and
are really useful one-on-one session
with Jools who also happens to now be
the channel manager for all the channels
that took part in next up
oh those vanilla trying to steal my
filming spotlight in my particular case
I realized that the majority of my views
come from
already subscribe to my channel so it's
great further I need to look through the
analytics of the videos that drew new
subscribers in and try and do the same
thing again after these workshops
oh that's Sergey of the dadlab we hit
undoubtedly my favorite part of the
whole week oh my god the second one is
my favorite bah bah bah bah after a
really fun session with two my favorite
creators Tom sky and Eddie about being
creative in which we did an exercise
where it turns out I suck at trying to
name things which are pink on the spot
we then had a session all about branding
Swedish did a session with Tom Scott Tom
rich hello so this is Jen who is very
bumpy at the moment which is why we're
lying on the floor yeah um what did we
just have a session relation yes
weird have you forgotten read it yeah
it's been a long week we did this
exercise so we had to list things that
are of the color another card what color
did you get I got what I can achieve 8
things the first thing wasn't difficult
and now we've got a session on what do
we have a session on brand brand in a
brand importance around so that when I
move my lips and this session was one of
the other major takeaways from the week
creating a channel brand is all about
thinking strategically something that
I've consciously tried to avoid doing up
till now to work out what your channel
is all about we went through exercises
like mind mapping words you want your
channel to be associated with and
identifying what your goals are with
what you're doing with the channel this
then allows you to better work out how
to achieve those goals the most useful
exercise was trying to put your channel
brief what your channels all about into
a tweet try it it's difficult the
session inspired me so much I
immediately had to do all these
exercises on my own and write down the
results but after this we then had
another one at the tree
laid on by Google a cocktail baking
class in which Tonya on my right who has
a channel about gardening and I fail at
following basic instructions like yeah
I'm going to get better at making the
drink the more in that demo I drink so
yeah we then had what was the most fun
part of the whole creator camp the
production challenge so while the first
half of the week was spent in seminars
going through the theory behind being ug
but if the second half was spent
actually making something we were split
into groups and tasked with making
something anything I was lucky enough to
be in a group with Greg from the Hoxton
trend and also three ludicrously
talented musicians and comedians and I'm
again Dan Forney ASPI world and Alex
Watts seen here shearing off we decided
that we were going to make a
mockumentary so the video that we're
making is a challenge Birla Group the
group's come up here for a creative
writing session because you know we're
all like trendy hip people and we work
outside open plan office and what is our
video about you can write and he come
back of course drunk so it's not next up
it's now isn't this exciting
so yeah this thing I won't talk about
Melvin later this is a view I could get
used to what my penis again no it's not
your penis it wasn't Emma who's just for
what our frame I'm in fact hooking up
this is out so red it's a very very nice
camera oh yeah also red Alex but a red
camera this thing is with more than my
degree well justice in their national
and
descending to make the ritual dance
begins
you guys look properly evil because
you're just sort of a little it from
that angle if there's nothing you
questions then yeah yeah we have a few
questions you know look at this
lightning also as well as a lighting
look at this we've been given a custom
time keep texting no oh hang on this
thing right yeah sorry
so I haven't filmed very much the I
could it's been so long has it the stuck
behind me this isn't moisture there are
three shoots happening at the moment so
it's regroup - well given us a challenge
to make a video these guys run along
with a lighting setup which is what we
did downstairs and we are currently
doing some b-roll but yeah I was pretty
busy this was something else but I
learned this week working on a
full-scale production with multiple
people high end gear and shooting to a
script is absolutely exhausting we spent
all day on Thursday shooting before
YouTube had a comedy night for us
educating is really hard that you never
thought of that
just make some progress
and then we went on to editing Fanta
Klee all day on Friday I was the guy at
the controls taking direction from
everyone behind me and this was more
than a bit stressful but after this we
had the experience of sitting down in a
room with all these fantastically
talented other creators and alumni from
next up and showing them what we made it
was a little bit scary but the thrill of
feeling an audience laugh and applaud
something that you made was just
extraordinary that's one of the most fun
things I learned this week if you'd like
to watch our creation by the way there's
a link to it in the description where
it's hosted on Alex's channel the
screenings felt like a combination of
everything we'd learned in the week and
this was capped off with a graduation
ceremony with personalized stash cap
throwing and more amazing Google food
for the occasion the wall of videos in
reception was co-opted by our videos I
was on YouTube in YouTube we've got a
bunch of awesome photos from the event
and more than that we walked there with
a bunch of new friends new skills and
lessons learned I can't stress enough
that if you're thinking of applying for
next up where you are do it I only
applied super last minute because my
friend Denis herself an alumna bug me
until I did and thank you for insisting
that I did in ask now it's my turn to
bug all of you I learned so much have so
much fun and now approach how I make
videos in a totally different way and
it's all thanks to next up and the team
the space Thank You Jules
Toby Fleur and everyone else for an
amazing week I'd be more than happy to
come back and give a talk when I'm super
famous I've got big plans for this
channel and I know that next up is going
to catalyze those plans and help me to
make the content I've always wanted to
make check out the other people's
channels link below and stick around on
this channel to see what I do with my
new YouTube superpowers I promise to use
them for good
you